I found it.
You said you'd pay more than the others.
I lied.
I was on your fishing boat, the Astghik.
I was the only one who survived.
Where are you now?
Okay. Stay there. I got to go.
The kids are ready. Who is that?
Oh, gosh, I almost forgot.
And if I don't, then you'll lose.
Your wife was a journalist the last couple of
years.
Fent it's Laura.
Nobody understands, do they?
One minute they're there and the next
minute.
I need you boys to pack up your stuff
tomorrow.
We're going to move to Bridgeport for the
summer.
We're going to find out what happened to Mom.
Hey. Hey. We believe you about what happened
on the Astghik.
Does this mean anything to you?
That symbol.
There's something inside. It's a box.
That's what got everyone killed.
I lied. Oh.
Oh.
Oh. Are you alright sir? He took my bag.
The guy got on a plane with his fake mustache
and then jumped off at 10,000ft.
Oh, you're home.
You're the guy.
That jumped out of that plane. You're a
fugitive.
Guilty.
What'd you steal? The less you know, the
better.
A box of your mom's things came to me.
The strange tales of Bridgeport.
Joe, Mom sent this out the day that she
died.
Somebody killed Mom. Your wife was
investigating something.
And my nephew Rupert was her source.
Do you remember any stories that your mother
was working on?
I mean, did you even know that she was
writing again?
No.
You made a copy of the report.
We got to take this to Dad's partner, Sam.
J.P. Cox.
This is the guy from the beach.
Take this envelope. Go to Stony Creek Park.
Find a bench. You put it under it.
I'm just telling them where to meet me.
He hid this in the vent in my room.
I think that's what the tall man was looking
for.
I had it with me during the carnival, and I
didn't lose a single game.
Whoa. The tall guy killed all the people in
the hashtag.
Rally for the idol.
Him and the guy from the beach.
They're after the same thing?
Today's the day J.B. is going to meet his
buyer.
If we find out who is after this thing.
Then we find out who killed Mom.
Joe! When I went back, the tall man found
us.
He's not going to stop looking for it.
So we're going to use that to our advantage
and we're going to trap him.
We think that all of this has something to do
with what got her killed.
I think it has something to do with my
grandmother and my great grandfather and this
weird power that they have over everything.
I'm just glad that you're here, because I
don't think I could have done this alone.
If you found what was in the idol.
You held a piece of it.
They called it the "Eye" because with it,
you could see what you needed to achieve all
your desires.
I think there's something weird about that
new girl, Stacy.
What's up with her?
Why are you so stuck on that girl? Or maybe
it's the fact that Frank stuck on her.
That's what's really bothering you.
Who are you? Stacy.
My name is Anastasia Nabokov.
I think whoever killed your mother probably
got to my father, too.
Where's your nephew now?
Now? Three weeks ago, he disappeared.
And I believe you're the man to find him.
Rupert Conn. You knew my wife.
I was helping her to destroy the circle of
the eye.
Ever since I heard, they found that piece on
the boat.
I've been thinking about my successor.
The legacy of the eye will fall to you,
Francis.
The only place the Eye can be broken or
reforged is in the chamber of the Eye where
we discovered it.
I think that it's the only place it can be
destroyed as well.
She said her family was running the town.
You're making them sound like they're a
secret organization.
That's what they are.
They called themselves the "Circle of the
Eye", the Nabokovs, the Khans, and the
Estabrooks.
Did Mom know about all of this?
Laura was very good at finding herself in
places she was not supposed to be.
Laura, you must never let your mother or
anyone else reassemble the Eye.
Mom wanted to expose the truth and bring down
the circle.
You don't want to destroy the eye, you want
it for yourself.
You're the same as everyone else.
You know, whatever happens now is on you.
Did you bring it?
Yes. Where is she? The piece.
Frank! Kelly!
Don't give her the peace.
Stacey is insane. You should have never given
her the piece.
We didn't...
Did it happen?
I gave them the girl. They gave me the piece.
Well hand it over. I don't.
It worked before I...
Stop! Oh...
Frank... Perfect timing. Fun's just about to
start.
It's over. We know everything.
You know nothing.
We have you on tape with Kanika Khan.
We know that you killed Victor Nabokov.
Stacey. I swear I didn't know.
I should have destroyed all the Estabrooks.
You took everything away from me.
Your father knew what he was getting into
when he came for my piece of the eye.
You deserve each other.
Get it now. Get the piece!
Remember me?
Frank! Help!
Frank! She's putting
it together! Frank...
It's me. It's Joe.
That's not the argument you had with her.
The day she died. You knew she was in danger.
You knew they were going to kill her. And
you just let it happen.
No.
I warned her I couldn't protect her anymore.
You didn't want to protect her.
No, no, no. She didn't give me a chance.
She was so angry with me.
She cared more about exposing the circle
than she did about her own safety.
You chose the eye over your own daughter.
You were the only other person who saw the
argument between my mom and grandmother.
You knew about the Astghik.
It was you...
You killed her.
No, no, no, no. That's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous. Tell them. Tell them.
That's wrong.
You couldn't have. You wanted to use the Eye
to do more than your father to do better.
She would have ruined it all.
What? She would have exposed everything.
I did it for you.
She was my daughter.
The chamber is collapsing.
Go. I'll get the eye.
Gloria Estabrook, you're under arrest for the
murder of Victor Nabokov.